YouTube oopsy poopsy and that's it good
evening I'm poppy Fourier lead anchor of
pew news the most esteemed news source
of all time our first news come YouTube
YouTube ad say it with me you too bad
they posted on Twitter saying many of
you has told us that we need to do a
better job preventing harassment on
YouTube doubt doubt I'm pressing the X
it's a big X here we consulted with a
wide array of creator style experts and
organizations to update a harassment
policy which changed today doubt here's
what it covers all right well let's read
through this let's break this down the
official blog let's go through it
doesn't matter the thing that I've
learned about YouTube's policies is that
it doesn't matter what they say what
matters is how they enforce it and we've
already seen how it's done they may they
change this harassment policy their
first move their first order of business
apparently was to remove idubbbz leafy
content cup that was it thank God they
updated the policy so they can get rid
of this video finally what if you read
the blog post it says beyond threatening
someone there is also demeaning language
that goes too far too far idubbbz too
far when I dub said chin small too far
it's so stupid
apparently allegedly leafy himself has
said that this is complete bogus his
whole channel leafy himself is made of
criticizing other channels come back
leafy come back we miss you we need you
diet we're in dire need over here heel
knee first of all why retroactive Lee
takes down videos if you're gonna make a
new policy change then go from there
don't go back in in old videos to say
actually this one this one bad what is
that fix reading more in this blog post
it's
clear that they made this as a response
to what happened earlier this year
between steven crowder and that vox guy
and Crowder was poking fun of his
homosexual mannerisms which I will not
replicate because whenever I think about
it I just can't believe anyone would do
that I'm joking of course we'll get more
into that harassment hurts our community
by making people less inclined to share
their opinion and engage with each other
we heard this from time and time again
from creators this does the opposite
YouTube creators are [ __ ] degenerates
they're the worst people out there
speaking from a youtuber we pull the
worst imaginable just to get views on
this side that's how we get paid thus
far yes I use that word the only thing
keeping these YouTube vultures in check
are other youtubers we have this anarchy
system okay and don't come and ruin it
for us YouTube the rule is if you do
dumb [ __ ] on YouTube you will get called
out on it
we need that it's the only thing keeping
us sane YouTube don't take it away from
us please a couple examples and this is
just a handful daddio five making videos
abusing children his own kids or step
kids I don't know was it YouTube that
strike down those videos was a YouTube
that took the first step in action to
make sure something happened there no no
it was other youtubers guess they can
just flag them down for bullying now the
same tactics is used I'm not gonna name
the scumbags name but it's same tactics
is used right now we're another
degenerate creator is getting criticized
by other youtubers the way the tactic he
uses to strike it down is to copy strike
those videos so he gets the money from
those creators now you're just giving
more tools to these scumbags to strike
down criticism Logan Paul showed a video
with a a [ __ ] dead body
a corpse it wasn't removed by YouTube no
no no no no no it was removed by Logan
after other people criticized him
promoting gambling to kids did YouTube
do anything about that no [ __ ] you know
it was other creators that notice it and
called it out making videos milking
people's reason
passing our YouTube gonna addict policy
for that because previous leads
youtubers telling people to not do these
things and otherwise they would get away
with it if YouTube know what's good at
them they'll keep their [ __ ] hands
out of this well-developed
100 percent unclog system where you dumb
you get called out that's just how it is
I don't dumb [ __ ] to I get called out
it's epic it's not epic actually but
it's good it's good for everyone
further on they say we've always removed
videos that explicitly threatened
someone reveal confidential information
and encourage people to harass someone
moving forward our policy will go and
step further and not only prohibit
explicit threats but also implied
threats we don't want to be dumb fury
enough so we're gonna dump three some
more we're gonna go a step further on
our dumb finish Bucky implied threats I
think it's really good because YouTube
100% knows the intent of people the
video called
and why they censored the thumbnail
because it was just completely horrible
it's called the death of HD HD it was a
video criticizing a straight street
whatever your opinion on the video is it
got removed and I think it was because
he was holding a gun towards h3h3 in the
in the thumbnail I think I think that's
how I remember it
eh trees it's scared for his safety
because today that video needed to be
gone I mean everyone knew a she or she
was in big trouble because of his
personal safety thanks to that thumbnail
I mean my god what do we have done no
one thinks he's going to shoot a tree
tree just cuz he holds up a gun no one
is fearing for a safety why are you
doing that why is there no distinction
between intent and actual action it's
not that hard to tell in a part in
English so I asked you to provide this
cuz I was kind of worried where they're
gonna draw the distinction and they said
that this tracks will fall under
artistic content and scripted comedy and
sanap is fine but you can't abuse the
artistic content as an excuse to keep
harassing someone a lot of people raise
the question I've seen other youtubers
being like okay so why can't late-night
show hosts you know make fun of Donald
Trump as an example because they're
pretty relentless with it to a point
where it just stop being funny years
ago but apparently it's an American
media rule this is just what I've heard
that says that you can ridicule public
figures that's fine thank God thank God
public figures are still up to ridicule
aren't we old public figures on YouTube
isn't that the point like this doesn't
make sense to me why do they get a pass
and some don't it seems very selective
if someone understands explain to me I
don't understand this it should be the
same and to summarize this I think it
seems the same case for a lot of
YouTube's update where the intention is
good I don't think people should get
attacked for their sexual identity or
but it's always like this is what we
want to strike down and then all these
other things and consequences is the
result of it and I don't understand how
that happens every time
it's like hopper wasn't enough there's
no kids content or YouTube and there's
no edgy content anymore on YouTube but
what we have here encapsulated it's very
nice very nice mmm delicious stale
content tastes so stale mmm
lights are coaching little big things
it's so boring but it's so media
friendly poppies Moorea from the future
here I don't have time to record this
but I wanted to make an update on the
whole cough less situation that I
covered last week for those of you don't
know now as a creator you have to tag
your video if it's made for kids or if
it isn't and there's a lot of confusion
based on what is family-friendly then or
what is made for kids and it's still
pretty unclear but hopefully we'll get
more update question mark where the
distinction is we sold ready that a lot
of channels were flying that's for kids
when they clearly were not and I got
really upset about it because I think
it's [ __ ] that YouTube besides and
then they're wrong when you could lose
up to 90 percent of your revenue but
according to what I've heard it's closer
to 60% okay it still sucks but the main
issue I'm making this update is because
because even if YouTube tag your video
ass made for kids
you can still remove that tag it's not
like a branding mating I don't know iron
fork or something you can still remove
it it doesn't matter what matters is
that you
make your own distinction if your
content is made for kids or not and the
fine that is quoted for the two thousand
from the FTC if you make it an issue is
only if you're a big youtuber and I'm
the one that's gonna get that fine if
your smaller youtuber and you happen to
get fine which seems unlikely because
they're not just gonna go over after the
bigger ones first anyway so it's still
very frustrating and it's still very
annoying but it's not as panic mode as
it seems at least that's what I gathered
from it so I just wanted to update you
guys on that back to PewDiePie in the
past as Maury publish Maury oh god its
next news the most searched people and
celebrities was revealed by prawn hub we
have Belle Delphine Kim K card appeal in
the plague Aryan the Nikki grab blabla
blabla blablabla PewDiePie who the [ __ ]
is searching PewDiePie on Valentine's
Day what is wrong with you
for five thousand percent increase five
thousand hey I beat Kendall Jenner suck
it Kendall you can suck it small peep
I'm gonna say it Kendall Jenner's smoke
peepee you can now vote for the creator
of the Year award go vote mr. piece
because everyone else on this list is
stale and boring and I hate them I was
kidding at some of these to get a patch
but I still hate them okay
video game awards happen that's a good
that's fun that's always fun I love
video game awards so did this guy Oh God
I tried to find the whole video games
awards online but it's been currently
blocked by wmg because of copyright
grounds YouTube 2019 everyone it just
keeps getting better and better that's
what I enjoy the most of the
step-by-step improvements that keep
occurring and it just makes it so great
I love it so much I think now it's a
great time as I need to announce I have
special announcement to make I am taking
break from YouTube next year I wanted to
say it in advance because I made up my
mind I'm tired I'm tired I'm feeling
very tired I don't know if you can tell
just so you know early next year I'll be
away for a little while I'll explain
that later but I wanted to give heads up
and that's it for me for now hope you
guys enjoyed this episode of pew news
I'm Popish Moria and I'm out sees I'm
smile sees that's good you have been
farting you are entering a new era where
you shall craft I own
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming
[Music]
marzia Edgar and buttons need you
the timer you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne routine is the game to play
I'm not supposed to have my opinion
about that but the prices